Halloween 3 is known as the Black Sheep
the Tokyo Drift the Zelda 2 of the
Halloween franchise for that reason the
series connections we've now come to
expect are more tenuous but if we
inspect the movie closely some of its
hidden secrets start to come into view
the story follows Dr Daniel chalice who
is called into the hospital to take care
of an injured patient and prescribes a
medication called Thorazine 100
milligrams Thorazine this calls back to
the first Halloween where Dr Loomis
plans to use the same drug to sedate
Michael Myers what do I give him when we
take him in front of the judge
barely be able to sit up that's the idea
after realizing the suspicious
circumstances of the patient's death
chalice decides to go investigate with
the man's daughter Ellie grimbridge
before leaving town he brings his
ex-wife at a payphone this is the same
location featured in Halloween 2. we're
the nurse Karen announces that she never
wants to go to another Halloween party
the biggest connection to the original
two Halloween movies though which many
viewers are not aware of has to do with
the reason that the villain Connell
Cochran has put this elaborate plan into
motion to learn the little known
connection between him and Michael Myers
stick around to the end of this video
[Music]
three more weeks till Halloween
Halloween Halloween
three more weeks till Halloween silver
Shamrock welcome to things you missed
just one year after killing off the
popular slasher Michael Myers series
producers John Carpenter and Deborah
Hill we're interested in continuing with
their original idea of an anthology
Series where each movie would tell an
unrelated story taking place on
Halloween night as always I'll be joined
in this video by the literal prime
minister of Haddonfield Jimmy champagne
it's commonly thought that Halloween 3
Season of the Witch Is the only movie in
the Halloween franchise that doesn't
feature Michael Myers but that's not
exactly true we see Michael in a
commercial for a television airing of
the original Halloween which tells us
that Halloween is only a movie in this
universe Tommy Lee Wallace was excited
by the prospect of getting to tell a new
story so after declining to take over
Halloween 2 he signed down as the
Director of the third installment that's
actually his voice in the silver
Shamrock commercials
with silver Shamrock masks gather round
your TV set put on your masks and watch
I learned this while trying to determine
if this was the same voice as Dr
dementia the horror movie marathon host
in the first two films
bolt your windows and turn off the
lights they're similar but I never did
find out if Dr dementia was voiced by
Tommy I mean I haven't heard otherwise
so let's just go with it Halloween 3 is
a weird movie but the same Oddities that
turned off critics and fans in the early
80s are part of what makes it a cult's
classic decades later with that all
being said let's get into the things you
missed
[Music]
the opening credits are displayed over a
series of lines appearing close up on a
TV screen we don't know it yet but what
we're seeing is a very zoomed in version
of the video that triggers the
brainwashed sequence I love how right
from the first shot you already know
this movie's gonna be funny and just the
way that this guy runs makes me laugh an
hour later he arrives at a gas station
where we see the news report about the
missing Stonehenge monuments it weighs
more than five tons making its
disappearance a mystery indeed I'm not
exactly sure why Cochrane felt like he
needed to steal the entire giant Stone
because he only ended up using like a
small chunk of that Monument to enact
his planned wouldn't it be smarter just
to take like the chunk you need instead
of removing an entire ancient Monument I
get that we find out that all you need
is an extremely small spec to do major
damage and that's what ends up in every
single silver Shamrock mask but still
the amount they're using in these masks
is absolutely tiny compared to that
massive Monument which everyone realized
was stolen so the Stonehenge news report
sets up the big reveal about what the
company's true intentions are but the
next program after this is also
significant when we come back Trina will
be here to tell you what you can do
about junk mail stay with us junk mail
is a form of overbearing advertising
which ties into the main message of this
movie the entire Crux of cochrane's plan
relies on children to be brainwashed by
the silver Shamrock commercials that
dominate the airwaves in the days
leading up to Halloween Michael Myers
may not show up to chase any teenagers
this time but Daniel chalice is
constantly chased by this catchy yet
annoying silver Shamrock jingle almost
every location in the movie has screens
or radios manipulating children to buy
their masks and wear them on the big
Halloween night giveaway there are so
many screens I started to wonder if I
wasn't at Universal Studios that's a
stupid joke we are totally joking
Universal please let us come to
Halloween Horror Nights this year just
as the first Halloween makes a comment
about the sexual Revolution still
ongoing from the 1960s Season of the
Witch Taps into concerns of the effects
of television on children a discussion
that was still picking up steam from the
late 1970s even though television is no
longer a relevant medium for young
people the themes of this movie remain
pertinent it was not that long ago that
YouTube implemented strict rules
regarding content made for children to
make sure that they aren't subjected to
targeted advertising and also a bunch of
other land restrictions for some reason
let's just say it was the only time ever
we're operating a horror themed Channel
actually paid off yo Zach let's make a
cocomelon horror movie yeah I'm sure
that one won't get us struck down off
YouTube immediately
we see the effects of over advertising
towards kids on chalice's own offspring
they each get silver Shamrock masks and
huddle around the TV when the commercial
comes out
[Music]
three horrific masks to choose from The
Masks are marketed as the big Halloween
3. yes let's go ahead and get our jokes
in about the title of the movie being in
the movie there are many threes or
triples in this movie and I'm not sure
how many of them are intentional so I'm
just gonna show them and let you decide
also of note the deadly silver Shamrock
program at the end is airing on three
different channels there are perhaps a
other number games at Play here Mr
grimbridge's room at the hospital is
room 13. if you've seen my final
destination videos you know all about
how that's the Unlucky number but in
this case it's also the reverse of 31.
as in October 31 Halloween night there
are also a lot of instances of the
number six the motel room that chalice
and Ellie stay in is room six the town's
curfew goes into effect at 6 pm and the
activation code for the commercial is
666 the Number of the devil it's not
just the numbers that we should be
paying attention to though there are
also several names that have a deeper
meaning than what meets the eye
[Music]
when chalice gets to the hospital his
new patient is Harry grimbridge a shop
owner who apparently discovered the
silver Shamrock secret and was hunted
down by the Androids who worked for Mr
Cochran the Assassin promptly leaves the
hospital gets into his Plymouth Fury and
self-destructs
when getting it made this might have
been yet another hint as to what one of
his future projects would be that's
because his adaptation of the Stephen
King novel Christine would come out a
few years later and for those of you who
don't know what that's about it's about
a kid who buys a cursed 1958 Plymouth
and then ends up destroying it because
it has a mind of its own and starts
killing people now the car in Halloween
3 isn't an exact match but it's the same
make and model so I feel like it's worth
bringing up nonetheless before you let
us up down in the comments I know that
John Carpenter has said multiple times
over the years that this is his least
favorite movie that he's ever made but
I've also seen recently that he started
to come around on it so yeah I
absolutely love it and I watch it all
the time I'm glad he started to like it
too is there also a second Stephen King
Connection in Season of the Witch
probably not but I'm gonna mention it
anyways inside Mr grimbridge's store
there are these Jack-in-the-Box clowns
in a box that says boats director Tommy
Lee Wallace would go on to direct a
production where a creepy clown steals a
young boy's bones it would not come out
for another eight years however so I'm
just gonna chalk this one up to just
being a a fun coincidence perhaps a more
intentional detail can be seen when
Ellie is brought in to ID her father
after his death the county sheriff's
name badge reads dunsmere dunsmear is a
small town in northern California much
like Santa Mira where the movie takes
place I wouldn't be surprised if
dunsmear was one of The Inspirations for
this location though it seems a little
bit less creepy than its film
counterpart Santa Mira is named after a
fictional town from an earlier sci-fi
horror movie and novel called Invasion
of the Body Snatchers this was the start
of a trend a lot of other properties
would borrow this fictional location for
their setting including Airwolf The Dark
Tower and even the Sharknado franchise
chalice hangs out in a bar where he is
once again bombarded by the overplayed
Halloween mask commercial he asked the
bartender to change the channel and he
puts on a football game which we can
hear in the background is Ellie
grimbridge introduces herself listen to
the names called out by the announcer
these are both references to crew
members of the movie Barry Bernardi was
an associate producer and Tommy Marshall
was best boy electrician there are a few
more for reference Easter eggs that I
spotted in the guest book when chalice
and Ellie get to the hotel including
costumer Francis Vega Aubry who signs as
both Francis Aubry and Mr F Vega and
property Master James Rathbun last
episode when we covered Halloween 2 I
mentioned how Nancy Loomis also known as
Nancy Kai's or keys I'm not exactly sure
how to say it appears in each movie in
the original Halloween Trilogy this time
she plays none other than Dr Dan
chalice's ex-wife Linda I've seen this
movie like 20 times and I never
connected that Linda is played by the
same actress as Annie mainly because she
comes off like such a huge another
actress who appears in each of the first
three Halloween movies is Lori Strode
herself Jamie Lee Curtis because we of
course see her during the television
airing of Halloween in this movie
foreign
I guess Dr chalice is not a fan the
other Jamie Lee Curtis Cameo is a bit
more covert it is her voice that
announces the early curfew in Santa Mira
it's six o'clock curfew
there's one other notable Cameo
appearance and it comes from dick
warlock this is the guy who played
Michael Myers in Halloween 2. so we see
him unmasked for the first time when he
appears as one of Connell Cochran's
Androids I know I don't normally talk
about actor cameos and things you missed
but it felt relevant to bring up since
this is a spiritual successor to the
first two movies it's kind of like how
shock dream into the follow-up to Rocky
Horror similar crew similar casts
similar artwork and feel but totally
different story on the drive to Santa
Mira chalice and Ellie read up on the
town proud Community predominantly Irish
Irish Halloween mask in California you
never know outside of the company
producing the mass being called Silver
Shamrock there are a lot of references
to Ireland and Irish culture so let's
just go over all of them to make sure
we've got our bases covered Dr chalice
and that weirdo he meets both appear to
be alcoholics heavy drinking is a common
trait of the stereotypical Irishman
drinking and doctoring great combination
another
known for
K the bar he hangs out at is decorated
with Irish murals for example this one
on the back wall is a depiction of Anne
Bonnie an Irish pirate from the 1700s
the other businesses in Santa Mira are
also themed to Irish culture Rafferty is
a classic Irish name Dublin is the
capital of Ireland the word Shamrock is
kind of overused in addition to the
factory there's also a shamrock store
and a shamrock savings though personally
I would have gone with leprechaun loans
they end up staying at the Rose of
Shannon Motel a reference to the town of
Shannon in Western Ireland the booking
office has a huge map of Ireland hanging
on the wall the cup for family arrives
at the motel in a big RV covered in
stickers it's hard to make them out but
one of them definitely has the colors of
the Irish flag while touring the factory
we learned that silver Shamrock used to
be known for making toys like these
wind-up machines this one depicts a
group of musically inclined insects
called the Love Bug band which is a
reference to an Irish pop band from the
80s known as lovebug the depiction of
them is insects may also be a connection
to the method by which the Halloween
masks killed the children they are
Zapped by this laser from the Stonehenge
piece which causes their brains to turn
into a swarm of insects that come
pouring out of their heads I don't care
what you think about this movie you
gotta love that kill it's a great
practical gag because you see it
see it Cochrane is targeting children
I'm gonna turn on the subtitles and all
right roll it
The Blacklist who play
the barriers would be done you see
in the rears and the unreal
and the dead might be looking in
sit by our fires of turf
Halloween
the Festival of someone did you catch
that although Cochran says it
differently than Dr Sam Loomis did in
Halloween 2 he tells us that children
are sacrificed during the Festival of
salad remember how Michael defaced the
chalkboard leading Loomis to believe
that his crimes were part of a tribute
it turns out that cochrane's plan to
eviscerate the minds of American
trick-or-treaters comes from a similar
motivation which makes this the only
through line between Halloween 2 and
Halloween 3. there is another hint about
the true purpose of the silver Shamrock
masks hidden in one small detail at the
motel
foreign
video would be complete without making
fun of the mature relationship between
Dr chalice and Ellie grimbridge I mean
her father just died earlier that week
and she's already trying to get it on
with a mustache man literally more than
twice her age seriously you're going to
investigate your father's murder why did
you even pack that outfit it's so
ridiculous playing an older guy who gets
with younger girls is exactly what Tom
Atkins was born to do I mean have you
seen the fog and I'm not even making
this up but I was looking into this
movie and learned that the scenes in
Santa Maria were filmed at a place
called Lolita California I do love a
good joke and this is the best ever
despite how unintentionally funny this
movie can be at times and believe me it
can be unintentionally funny
foreign
but despite all of that the way the
mystery set up is actually really well
done or at least kind of well done there
are a lot of details that set up the
fact that the factory workers are robots
like the explanation of the hiring
process he brought in every damn one of
them Factory people from the outside
you think you hired me local boy
no way turn me down flat and the
realization that the initial assassins
autopsy only contains machine parts
we've been doing an autopsy on part of
the car it's still hilarious when you
first hear it there's also a little
foreshadowing about the magic element of
cochrane's plan at the motel a woman
named Marge Gutman can be seen reading
Carlos estranadas the Eagles gift from
what I understand this book is about
sorcery although the magic used to
sacrifice The Mask wearing children is
referred to as witchcraft and although
one of the big Halloween three masks is
a witch there isn't an actual witch in
the movie I read somewhere that Tommy
Lee Wallace named it after the Donovan
song Season of the Witch great song but
it is also not in the movie the finale
shows as kids going out to trick or
treat all over the country which by the
way includes some beautiful shots of the
Halloween Sunset chalice rescues what he
thinks is Ellie but actually turns out
to be robo-ellie not sure how or why
Cochrane had the time to make a perfect
replica of her just to screw with old
chalice or why the robo Ellie never
tries to stop him until after he's
destroyed the factory but whatever I'm
in the to this
I gotta say I love this movie's generous
take on how many cities actually
celebrate Halloween anymore I mean I've
lived in La like five years and I've
never once had a kid come to my door to
trick-or-treat on Halloween yeah I was
disappointed to see the lack of
decorations on most houses when I moved
out here after fighting her off he
inexplicably leaves the car behind and
goes to the gas station where the movie
started to try to get the hypnotic
advert taken off the air who goes
trick-or-treating at a gas station
apparently these kids do and they gather
around the TV as Dr chalice begs the
programmer to take the commercial off of
the three channels that it's airing on
wait you never went trick-or-treating at
a gas station do they get out gas or
candy I don't remember this brings us
back to the main theme that I discussed
about Halloween 3. the silver Shamrock
advert is representative of every TV
commercial attempting to corrupt and
brainwash the youth into becoming their
ideal consumer regardless of any harm
that this might be doing to them
physically or psychologically the bugs
and snakes that pour out of the young
copper boy's head are symbolic of what
is going on inside the heads of children
who are exposed to overbearing
advertising from a young age the parents
of these kids do show some concern
saying things like don't sit too close
or turn down the volume but ultimately
the kids are drawn to the flashy colors
and catchy tunes of the broadcast during
the factory tour we learned that silver
Shamrock used to be a toy manufacturer
and eventually switched to hypnotic
masks and television programs in the
1980s when this movie takes place
television was reaching the peak of its
popularity and Cochrane was just
following what the kids were paying
attention to TV shows were the new toys
and silver Shamrock is a stand-in for
any number of malicious private
companies ready to take advantage of
that like most good movies satire
Halloween 3 was ahead of its time I
think it's because it's hard to notice
that stuff when it's still happening all
around you but then when you revisit a
movie a few years later all of the
satirical jokes hit you right on the
head it's kind of funny that 40 years
later stranger things 3 covered the
exact same stuff as Halloween 3. yes and
I'll definitely have to think about
covering that on my channel sometime
soon as well
hint but if the years since 1978 have
taught us anything it's that you can't
kill Michael Myers and even if you could
he just won't stay dead for long the
Halloween Anthology concept was
abandoned after the poor reception of
Halloween 3 and in 1988 the prolific
slasher would wake up and set his sights
on a new Target which means we've got
more things you missed to discuss in
Halloween form the return of Michael
Myers meanwhile there is a new Halloween
movie Halloween kills just one week away
Jimmy's been covering everything related
to kills lately on his channel so head
over there and drop him a sub otherwise
he'll be forced to subscribe champagne
me champagne subscribe to Jamie
champagne
and click that video on the left and if
you love Halloween make sure to
subscribe to cz's world for new Horrors
every week ring the death bell for all
notifications and I'll see you in the
next one assuming we both survive
[Music]